[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le journal de tv 78 pour
faire un tour de l'actualité locale tout
de suite les titres de ce jeudi 26
septembre
il a été le 22e président de la
république française entre 1995 et 2007
jacques chirac est décédé aujourd'hui à
l'âge de 86 ans à l'ancien chef d'état
qui a été à l'origine de la carrière
politique de nombreux élus du
département dans cette édition et les
réactions et témoignages des yvelinois
suite à cette disparition conseil
municipal tendue hier à plaisir sous
fond de désaccord avec le maire trois
élus ont décidé de rejoindre le groupe
d'opposition la république en marge des
départs qui porte à neuf le nombre de
défections au sein de la majorité depuis
et puis cet atelier est menée à but pour
la deuxième année consécutive dans le
cadre de leur réinsertion cinq personnes
condamnées conçoivent une bande dessinée
en compagnie des rocs
une réalisation qui sera présenté lors
du festival de la bd en octobre prochain
et puis tout à l'heure en plateau deux
auteurs elles sont les auteurs un des
mes versailles 200 adresses pour
découvrir ou redécouvrir la cité royale
est la mort du 22e président de
l'histoire de la république française
jacques chirac s'est éteint ce jeudi à
l'âge de 96 ans affaiblie depuis
plusieurs années par un avc en 2005 et
plusieurs hospitalisations pour
infection pulmonaire jacques chirac
c'est une longue carrière politique
débutée en corrèze en 1965 une ascension
rapide qui le conduira à la présidence
de la république en 95 poste qu'il
occupera jusqu'en 2007 avant de se
retirer du monde politique le chef
d'état était aussi plusieurs fois
ministre premier ministre sous valéry
giscard d'estaing et françois mitterrand
ainsi que maire de paris il a été le
fondateur également du rpr puis de l'ump
deux formations historiques de la droite
écoutez la réaction de quelques
yvelinois suite à cette disparition
collectées par mathilde et demi et manon
par altran j'adhérais pas forcément
assez dit et politique mais je pense que
comme tout le monde doit on doit on doit
l'honorer
et voilà sinon je suis un peu
indifférente
enfin moi je l'aimais bien chirac il a
un côté sympathique surtout quand ils
allaient au salon de l'agriculture
il savait
discuter le bout de gras et les paysans
ça il était sympathique en fait toutes
mes condoléances pour toute sa famille
sa femme son épouse sa fille claude que
je connaissais très bien et puis toute
la france entière quoi parce que on peut
dire ce qu'on veut de lui quand même il
a été un bon président a quand même à
jacques chirac qui s'est rendu à de
nombreuses reprises dans les yvelines
lors de déplacements présidentiels
notamment en 1999 à vélizy villacoublay
une rencontre avec les chefs
d'entreprises du territoire en 2006 vous
le voyez sur ces images il a reçu à la
chancelière allemande angela merkel dans
les locaux de la préfecture à versailles
pour une rencontre franco allemande
visite inédite d'un président français
dans les locaux de la préfecture depuis
le général de gaulle autres chefs d'état
reçues sur le sol yvelinois il faut
remonter quelques années en arrière en
c'est nelson mandela qui avait été reçue
le 13 juillet 1996 alors qu'il était
président de l'afrique du sud il a été
reçu au château de rambouillet et les
allées du château est également en
visite boris elstine anciens dirigeants
de la russie et jacques chirac qui a été
à l'origine de la carrière de nombreux
ténors politiques du département alain
gournac jean-marie teta pierre lequiller
ou encore pierre bédier l'actuel
président du conseil départemental a
fait ses débuts aux côtés de jacques
chirac en 1976 il a participé en 1995 à
la campagne présidentielle où il se voit
confier l'animation des fédérations rpr
de 2002 à 2004 l'yvelinois était
secrétaire d'état en charge des
programmes immobiliers de la justice
pierre bellier que mathilde et demi a
joint par téléphone ému il raconte avec
nostalgie est l'homme qui l'a poussé à
faire de la politique dans les années 70
parce que je me serais sont pas engagés
s'il n'avait pas été là ces
personnalités hors normes
les mêmes anecdotes plutôt monde son
énergie sa gentillesse est il aimait
bien rigoler tout en étant quelqu'un de
sérieux
c'était vraiment quelqu'un d'immense pas
simplement ce qu'ils étaient prises en
partie parce que c'était sa personnalité
rayonnante autre homme politique à
s'être exprimé le président du sénat
gérard larcher l'ancien maire de
rambouillet était un proche de jacques
chirac il a été à deux reprises ministre
du travail lors du deuxième mandat du
président de la république soit les
gouvernements raffarin et de villepin
est dans un communiqué vous voyez les
principales déclarations s'afficher
gérard larcher se rappelle de l'homme
des territoires qu'il a sans cesse
arpenté au travers de ses fonctions en
corrèze et puis au sein de la mairie de
paris jacques chirac qui a incarné la
france dans le monde à travers ses
valeurs en refusant d'intervenir en irak
et aussi lors de son discours sur le vel
d'hiv
enfin le président du sénat estime que
jacques chirac a été le premier
président à alerter sur l'urgence
climatique se référant à sa célèbre
déclaration en 2002 notre maison brûle
et nous regardons ailleurs
réaction du côté du sénat toujours la
sénatrice les républicains à des
yvelines sophie primas l'était en séance
pour le vote d'un texte lorsqu'elle a
appris le décès de l'ancien chef d'état
écouter mes chers collègues c'est avec
beaucoup d'émotion et beaucoup de
tristesse
je viens d'apprendre le décès de jacques
chirac président de la république et je
voulais vous en faire part
je voulais vous proposer si madame la
présidente l'acceptent que nous fassions
d'ores et déjà un tout petit moment de
silence s'il vous plaît et vous l'avez
senti dans la voix de la sénatrice un
moment difficile
elle qui est héritière de valeurs
gaullistes elle a connu jacques chirac
au travers d'un proche
henri cuq député de la 9e
circonscription des yvelines entre 1988
et 2004 puis entre 2007 et 2010 sophie
primas était sa suppléante elle a été
interrogée par nicolas landry
ça va on est en train d'étudier en ce
moment au sénat
projet de loi sur l'économie circulaire
et m'en fais référence à lui tout le
temps c'est séduit kkk poser le problème
écologique en france et donc qu'on est
dans cette période où sénat où on pense
beaucoup à lui j à titre personnel de
souvenir je le vois entrer dans l'église
d'où dans un peu difficilement déjà dit
ferlo mehdi pour le les obsèques d'henri
cuq et je le vois aussi pétillant de
malice et de bonheur à la maison
d'accueil spécialisée de nîmes est là
qui porte d'ailleurs le nom d'henri cuq
et qui accueille des adultes handicapés
et il était venu l'inaugurer
voilà donc j'ai ce souvenir là la
carrière politique de jacques chirac se
sont aussi à deux périodes de
cohabitation dont l'une d'elles entre
1997 et 2002 lorsqu'il était président
de la république dans le gouvernement de
lionel jospin libye noise catherine
tasca officié comme ministre de la
culture et de la communication entre
2000 et 2002 l'ancienne députée
sénatrice socialiste du département se
souvient de sa collaboration avec le
chef d'état pour moi je suis très triste
d'abord parce que je trouve qu'il a été
privé d'une vieillesse heureuse à cause
de ça de sa maladie tellement qui a pris
très au sérieux sa responsabilité à
l'égard de la culture à l'égard des
cultures du monde entier
j'ai eu à travailler avec lui sur le
projet du thé branly et sur le projet du
jury mais que nous avons restauré la
relation est très simple et très
agréable c'était un président de la
république y décrocher facilement son
téléphone pour appeler directement tel
ou tel
donc j'en ai bénéficié dont j'ai apporté
mon soutien à ces deux projets autant
pour le pouvaient et de nombreuses
villes des yvelines vont rendre hommage
à l'ancien chef d'état saint germain en
laye la municipalité a décidé de mettre
dès aujourd'hui ses drapeaux en berne
une minute de silence sera également
observée ce soir lors du conseil
municipal la commune et jacques chirac
était notamment liée par là
péricard l'ancien maire de 1977 à 1999
c'est michel péricard était un ami
intime de l'ancien président son fils
arnaud péricard et lui mer aujourd'hui
de la ville yvelinoise anneaux arnaud
péricard qui s'est confié à miquel et
demi d'euros la criirad qui est élu
maire de paris en vue d'un franc 77 et
au début des années 80 il avait pris un
engagement et l'encan se gagnerait dans
la scène et je me souviens être allé
avec lui elle répond faire sur un bateau
sur la seine
ramasser les débris et les troncs
d'arbres ils oublient que ce que mon
père et captura qu'on fait des 277 pour
le paris saint-germain
je me souviens de voilà deux acura
pourtant des laudes
je me suis bien d'autres personnalités
biennoises ont réagi sur twitter après l
annonce du décès de l'ex président de la
république ont fait le point à décorer
les ronces réaction très sobre de la
présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse avant d'entrer en
politique en 2002 elle avait été
conseillère de jacques chirac à l'elysée
et pour la petite anecdote c'est elle
qui avait appris à l'époque au président
à manier les nouvelles technologies est
lui aussi a côtoyé de près l'ancien
président le préfet des yvelines jean
jacques brot a été l'un de ses
collaborateurs au début des années 2000
il parle d'un homme d'état pragmatique
la députée yvelinoise or berger remercie
l'ancien chef d'état pour son engagement
sur l'écologie ainsi que son discours
sur la rafle du vel d'hiv
pour la première fois en 1995 un
président reconnaissait la
responsabilité de la france dans les
déportations de juifs
pour le maire de poissy karl olive la
france pleure le grand jacques et lui
dit merci président de son côté le
sénateur yvelinois michel laugier évoque
un homme humain et chaleureux homme
qu'il avait eu l'occasion plusieurs fois
d'interviewer dans les années 80
lorsqu'il était journaliste
enfin le maire de rambouillet marc
robert souligner sa politique humaniste
tourner vers les territoires
l'ancien président s'était rendu à
plusieurs reprises à rambouillet et
avait notamment accueilli nelson mandela
je vous propose à présent d'écouter ce
témoignage celui du marquis
henri-françois de breteuil propriétaire
du château de breteuil à choisel dans
les yvelines
elle c'est dans les années 50 qui leur
rencontre celui qui n'est alors que
conférencier à sciences po paris est les
deux resteront ensuite très proche le
marquis breton qui s'est confié au micro
de patrick jacques de dixmude et matic
de 2010 cependant j'ai beaucoup aimé
cette maison sciences po j'ai eu aussi
des professeurs exceptionnels et je
mettais à j'étais arrivé trop tard parce
que vous savez on s'inscrit à sciences
po en première année et puis comme
j'étais parti aux états unis
je suis arrivé in extremis la sueur m'a
dit reste une un maître de conférences
tous les autres sont pris les plus
connus tout il s'appelle chirac
moi j'ai dit bon ben je pense chirac
j'ai pas le choix de toute façon
j'aimerais et c'est vrai que jacques
chirac va beaucoup frappé il a été mon
maître de conférences à sciences po et
c'est quelqu'un qui qui sûrement et
beaucoup d' influence sur moi ils
souvent que c'est un peu comme à comme à
m il faut savoir qu'il était tout jeune
il est moi j'avais 17 ans il en avait 28
ce qui me frappait beaucoup c'est son
dynamisme sa manière de d'être avec les
étudiants extrêmement comment dire
vaillant en quelque sorte et été et au
fond tout le monde était très très
conquis par nuit bars à sa manière
d'être et c'est très très frappant
enfants moi j'ai mangé une femme honnête
avec lui et c deja qu on appelait les
notes de conférence mais ils étaient ils
pouvaient être idée très sévère n'a pas
été avec moi j'ai la chance j'ai des
amis qui qui était d'une charmante jeune
femme qui sortait jusqu'à 3 heures du
matin qui arrivent avec des yeux tirer
comme ça
chirac dit mademoiselle quand on porte
le nom vous portez on n'a pas le droit
de
des ses fils et ses études et liamine
une note éliminatoire de conférences de
méthode
donc il pourrait être sévère mais il
était super dynamique
bien que certains que sa manière de
marcher dans les couloirs de sciences po
ouvriers ils arriveraient que ces grands
pas et sert à l'heure pile il était
comme ça
donc moi il m'a beaucoup bon beaucoup
appris
je dirais justement dans dans la
politique de la france tout simplement
dans
également la politique étrangère et il
est et il était très très présent dans
tous ces domaines il y avait des choses
amusantes avec chirac c'est que quand il
y avait un étudiant qui posait une
question un petit peu comme on dit un
petit peu je dirais pas insidieusement
fait un petit peu un petit peu précise
un petit peu assommante
or chirac avait cette phrase
extraordinaire passons sur les détails
et remettez à sa place les étudiants qui
avaient voulu les grilles cassé les
pieds mais je n'ai bien connu que j'ai
connu en première année ensuite en
seconde année à sciences po gt sont
insistants et puis par la suite j'ai
revu dans un temps à l'elysée ici
vraiment quelqu'un que j'ai beaucoup
d'avenir et j'aime bien aussi son épouse
je connais un petit peu la famille et
une histoire c'est un entrepôt de son
épouse c'est que quand on est élu il a
été élu
au conseil municipal de sainte féréole
est un tout petit bled en corrèze et la
coutume dit que quand on est élu au
conseil municipal pour la première fois
ont fait un grand buffet campagnard
on amène toutes les victuailles pour
inviter tout le vrai tout le village
alors je voyais chirac y préparer tout
ça moi je l'aidais un petit peu à tout
mais dans sa 403 et là dessus de voir
madame chirac qui ne bouge pas je suis
dit madame vous n'allez pas ce soir avec
votre mari à sainte féréole elle a eu
cette phrase définitive
non jamais je ne laisserai jacques faire
de la politique
et elle a été ensuite un grand supporter
de son mari j'ai cru dès le début donc
il avait 28 ans que ce quelqu'un qui ré
pierre est très loin peut-être parce
qu'ils avaient ce ce côté très très
mordant très très personnelle en fin de
en forme en plus les étudiants et serra
et j'ai pas été en fait j'ai pas été
surpris j'ai suivi beaucoup sa carrière
après j'ai revu dans un temps mais pas
autant que j'aurais même et j'ai vu de
même de temps en temps mais ils avaient
vraiment comment dire il avait une et on
a senti dès le début qu'il allait se
passer quelque chose avec ce bonhomme
s'était pas juste un nain politique
comme un autre
et ceci fait que j'ai suivi un peu sa
carrière à matignon également les soucis
qu'il a eus je suis allé deux fois en
corrèze et dans sa maison et je me
souviens de c'était l'époque où giscard
de m
oui je crois était président de la
république et il m'avait dit je lui
avais dit mais vous allez vous présenter
au prochain coup et cetera il m'a dit oh
je ne sais pas toutes façons giscard il
a mis la barre sur ses talons donc et
puis il avait ce charmant petit château
très modeste en corrèze
et donc c'était on s'attendait à ce
qu'il se passe quelque chose comme ça
c'était pas quelqu'un de deux légers
voilà il était très très très costaud
politiquement raconte au début on a vu
qu'il a des problèmes bien sûr les cet
accident de voiture qu'il a un moment
les élections européennes qui la
chesnaie il est il a des gros problèmes
sinon dans la vie ça a été quelque chose
s'est passé n'est pas été un long fleuve
tranquille
il a et il est toujours arriver
finalement à retomber sur ses pattes
mais a finalement être élu président la
république
il était fidèle en amitié moi j'ai la
chance que il m'est donnée
la croix de chevalier les gens d'honneur
et la croix d'officier légion d'honneur
à l'elysée
ce qui fait qu'à ce moment là vous
n'êtes pas obligé de faire des discours
c'est le président qui fait un discours
et après le récipiendaire j'ai pas dis
source parce que c'est très délicat de
dire je suis un mec formidable j'ai fait
si j'ai fait ça moi ça me déplaisait
outrageusement et je les ai revus à
l'elysée dans différentes manifestations
de temps à autre c'est clair alors c'est
curieux jacques chirac
il disait qu'il avait beaucoup de talent
il n'avait pas beaucoup de même de
mémoire c'est très curieux ces quantités
des discours souvent ils avaient un
papier
vous l'avez remarqué sur noir et il
n'était pas voilà il n'avait pas une
mémoire comme comme françois mitterrand
j'ai un tout petit peu connue aussi
qu'il y avait une mémoire mais
phénoménal voilà pour ce témoignage du
marquis de breteuil le président de la
république
emmanuel macron à lui a prévu de faire
une allocution télévisée ce soir à 20
heures et demain vendredi dans le 7-8
l'hebdo nous reviendrons bien sûr sur le
décès est de jacques chirac d'autres
réactions à vous proposer notamment être
d'élus de saint quentin en yvelines qui
se réunissent ce soir en conseil
d'agglomération
voilà ce qu'on pouvait vous dire sur
cette actualité jacques chirac qui
s'était éteint ce jeudi à l'âge de 86
ans
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité yvelinoise
une situation décidément entendu dans
les communes à quelques mois des
municipales à plaisir hier mercredi lors
du conseil trois élus de la majorité
plaisir oiseaux est annoncé leur
démission pour rejoindre les bancs de
l'opposition le récit de la soirée avec
nicolas d'andré trois nouveaux membres
dans les rangs de l'opposition brice
fabre hybris voir un métairie et patrick
jouin terre ont rejoint le groupe
ensemble avant son pur plaisir affiliés
à la république en marche
une décision annoncée est expliqué en
début de conseil municipal
ça fait plus de deux ans que nous
lançons des alertes sur un certain
nombre de dérives que ce soit des
dérivants en termes de gestion des
dérives en termes d'orientation
nous ne sommes pas d'accord sur les
priorités qui ont été choisis par
exemple dans le mode de fonctionnement
c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas la
main sur le choix des travaux qui sont
faits dans les rues nous n'avons pas la
main sur le contrôle de la voirie nous
n'avons pas la main sur un certain
nombre de priorisation des actions des
grands projets qui sont faits or les
plaisirs en attendent ce genre de
priorité un petit exemple on fait un
certain nombre de travaux dans le parc
du château
alors qu'on attend des pistes cyclables
ces trois démissions de quoi lancer les
élections municipales 2020 à plaisir
surprise pas trop vraiment plus tôt je
dirais une confirmation et bien d'un
opportunisme qui me semble évident parce
que quand on partage cinq ans et demi
des projets communs quand on travaille
ensemble pendant cinq ans et demi je
peux que m'interroger je dirais sur les
vrais fondamentaux d'une démission comme
celle ci à quelques mois des élections
nous sommes en proximité permanente des
habitants on entend bien le retour des
habitants sur tout ce que nous avons
fait depuis cinq ans et demi aujourd'hui
on se dit simplement que c'est peut-être
un peu dommage de voir que encore une
fois la politique donne une image comme
celle ci c'est la deuxième démission au
sein de la majorité au cours de ce
mandat plusieurs conseillers municipaux
avaient été démis de leurs fonctions au
sein de la majorité en 2016 sur un
désaccord à propos de fiscalité locale
politique encore avec cette information
tv 78 alors qu'il lançait en avril
dernier l'association engagement pour
trappe dans pour aller plus loin dans
son engagement pour la commune mustapha
larbaoui ne se lance finalement pas dans
la course aux municipales 2020 en tant
que tête de liste il ne ferme cependant
pas la porte à la politique trappistes
et attend des propositions pour son
groupe et déclarations au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
j'ai décidé de ne pas être tête de liste
aux municipales à trappes
en revanche depuis 18 mois j'ai
constitué une équipe une équipe avec
laquelle je souhaiterais travailler de
compétences de gens de bonne volonté des
gens qui connaissent cette ville les
gens qui connaissent les dossiers qui
sont prêts à travailler et donc je lance
un appel maintenant à tous ceux qui
veulent oeuvrer pour le bien commun de
cette ville pour l'intérêt général de la
commune un appel pour dire que je suis
prêt à rejoindre une liste dans laquelle
vous pourrez associer donc engagement
trappe
mon groupe est en raison de l'actualité
chargée avec le décès de jacques chirac
le reportage sur l'atelier bd à bulles
dont je vous parlais dans les titres
sera retrouvé lundi dans le journal sur
tv 78 pour refermer à cette édition deux
invités avec moi une cécile de la
martinière et corinne martin rozès mon
sens mesdames ça alors vous êtes toutes
les deux créatrices d'un côté de zoom
versailles points comme et de l'autre
vous êtes blogueuse pour versailles in
my pocket et vous avez publié le 19
septembre dernier aux éditions un ardagh
à aimer versailles alors c'est un livre
où vous retrouvez 200 idées de sorties
de sans adresse pour découvrir
redécouvrir la cité royale déjà pendant
de la genèse de ce projet pourquoi
associer vos deux expériences pour pour
faire ce livre j'avais eu l'idée
parce que sur zone vers ça justement on
a un carnet d'adressés entre autres un
et de l'actualité sur la ville de
versailles et j'ai eu l'idée voilà de
ceux de ce guide
mais versailles et j'ai contacté les
éditions mardaga pour savoir si elle
était intéressée puisqu'il existait déjà
une quinzaine de villes et quand ça
m'apparaissait
normal d'y associer les expertises de
corinne dont je vais tout de suite c'est
la première personne que j'ai appelé
pour lui proposer ce projet là puisque
corinne est référente via son blog sur
toutes les nouvelles adresses et à une
connaissance de versailles très
exhaustive ce sont douze habitants de
passionnés qui ont contribué à cet
ouvrage
oui parce que le collectif zoone
versailles a mené 11 11 11 membres à
l'équipe puisse moi ça faisait 12
pourquoi traiter cette ville de
versailles vous la faites vous faites au
quotidien pourquoi c'est intéressant de
traiter ce sujet parce qu'en fait on est
animé par la même passion toutes les
deux avec anne cécile et avec les autres
membres de zoom s'est vraiment montré
que la ville de versailles change qui
qu'elle est plein de pépites de
personnes formidables qui font des
entreprennent qui ont des idées que
c'est très très loin de l'image
poussiéreuse qu'on a de la ville très
classique et on a envie on avait envie
de montrer que ça change et maintenant
je le fais depuis huit ans sur mon blog
zoom le fait aussi depuis quelques
années et avec ce guide on avait envie
de passer à une version papier quelque
chose aussi qu'on peut offrir
et c'était une entreprise qui nous a
séduit toutes les deux sens là alors je
crois qu'au départ avec cette mise en
commun vous étiez à 400 adresses comment
vous êtes passé à 200 adresses fut qu'au
total il ya 200 adresses dans ce livre
est concrètement vous voulez vraiment
que ce soit révélateur de la ville et on
voulait et c'est l'originalité de ce
guide notamment par rapport aux autres
c'est effectivement que c'est une
communauté de versailles d'or déjà comme
le disait corinne on est déjà à zoom on
est déjà une équipe assez conséquente
et à démultiplier en fait notre réseau
et notre connaissance donc concrètement
première réunion j'avais demandé à
chacune d'apporter leur adresse et on a
fait des tours de table on sait on a
beaucoup discuté il y avait des
évidences des adresses où on ne s'est
pas posé de questions et puis d'autres
on était moins sûre donc on les a
testées on a on a on a fait des
recherches
voilà on était simplement aller voir
notre critère c'était vraiment on a
bataillé sur certaines adresses
notre critère c'était vraiment s'ils ont
recommandé à des amis ces questions font
d'ailleurs un des exemplaires ce que
vous en avez amené deux je le montrais à
la caméra et y organiser comment
justement ce livre plusieurs rubriques
oui il ya plusieurs rubriques
traditionnellement c'est une collection
où les rolex appel et met donc on a aimé
faire les boutiques aimer manger un
morceau aimé les gourmandises de toute
attaque
mse l'année je ne sais plus je vous
adresse sur la périphérie voilà c'est
vraiment un outil
voilà on va aller au resto on a enlevé à
boire un coup avec des amis on veut se
divertir c'est vraiment un site ils sont
à peine un city guide c'est à dire
toutes les adresses locales
c'est à la cnce ya laissé une sélection
et c'est ça reste ce fût subjectif voilà
mais s'est organisée autour de ca de sa
vie tout simplement et des différentes
attentes qu'on peut on peut y avoir en
ça ce n'est pas du tout un guide
touristique un vraiment on n'est pas du
tout prix cette optique là c'est un
guide de 2 pour vivre le haut niveau de
local comme un habitant ce guide du coup
on le trouve en librairie dans toutes
les librairies et toutes les plateformes
et mais versailles c'est aux éditions
mardaga 200 aux adresses utiles pour
découvrir redécouvrir
elle a cité royale versailles merci à
vous d'être passé en plateau anne-cécile
de la martinière et corinne martin rozès
merci d'être passé voilà assez à la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
dans un instant retrouver toutes les
idées de sorties dans le 7-8 loisirs
présentée par mélanie poquet belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]